Dan Attias, Director, Producer and Author: When
you get a script that looks challenging and
the easiest thing to do is say it can't be done.
Film Courage: What made Snowfall season
three episode one a challenge for you?
Dan: Well what was most challenging about it was
how big it was meaning how many huge sequences
were scripted a season premiere episode is needs
to be exciting it needs to pack a lot in to kind
of sustain audiences interest to come back for
future episodes and and in season three it was
one of the most this this was a show in case your
viewers don't know about it which dealt with the
crack cocaine epidemic in the early 80s in South
Central Los Angeles and there was so much packed
into this particular episode there were stunt
sequences there were aerial sequences there was
deep interpersonal things going on and so whenever
I'm given a script to read or that I'm going to
direct I try to read it at first putting aside all
those considerations I was trying to first because
I one of the challenges I had transitioning from
being an assistant director to becoming a director
is to stop being an assistant director to
stop looking at something in terms of the
difficulty to do it but instead to look at how
this story is affecting me how might I tell the
most exciting wonderful story exploring all of his
depths as possible and let myself dream about it
and so I'll read a script just letting it
wash over me and seeing what interests me
determining what is it really about what
what am I drawn to in the characters
because I can't really know how difficult it is
to shoot it within the time and budget constraints
until I figure out what story I'm telling where
I want the emphasis to be how I'm going to do
certain things some things that read difficult
as being difficult might be shot very simply
some things that seem simple might
be very very complicated to shoot
so in this particular instance there was no
getting around that this was just a bear of
the show in my book I do have a chapter oh
great let me see I think I summarize in it
here's the book I think I think I summarized what
the issues were what the sequences were let's see
when I was hired to direct the opening episode
of the third season of the fx show Snowfall
I was presented with a script that included an
ambitious opening stunt sequence on the streets
of South Central l.a as well as a sprawling
nighttime shootout a shocking murder of one of
the recurring characters a bar fight an aerial
stunt sequence culminating in a crash landing
on a mexican airstrip a grand opening celebration
the rekindling of a romantic of a romance between
two lead characters a lengthy nighttime driving
sequence ending in a nightmarish reveal of a crack
house plus many other highly charged sequences
it was a well-written densely packed script and
it promised to be a great kickoff to the season
but it was huge so Snowfall was on is on the FX
network and that's a basic cable channel it's
not the budget of Snowfall is nothing like
things like Game of Thrones or The Marvelous Mrs
Maisel where the production values are opulence so
as as a director coming in any show you have
to accept the givens what the limitations are
and the budget is one of the significant ones but
each show including Snowfall is aspiring for the
same number of viewers you wanna you wanna
to to make it as compelling as possible so
i did have to prep in order to figure out how
much we could do I had to prep all of the various
sequences and you work in in conjunction with the
assistant director who's scheduling the show as
you're going and you try to find out originally
what I what I initially what I try to do is
get a sense of what would it take to shoot this
episode not like if you have an eight-day schedule
how do we fit this into eight days no i'd like a
realistic estimate of how many 12-hour days would
we need to shoot this entire script and some
assistant directors are reluctant to do that
because they feel their bosses are wanting them
just no no say we can all do it but you don't want
to be put in a situation where you can't succeed
you don't want to be put in a position to fail
so the show is the show it's a high quality show
so I know everybody wants it to be good you're
not going to be able to do it badly so to do it
up to the standards of the show and up to my own
standards what would it take and it might take
well to do all of that it's going to be 12 days
well okay we don't have 12 days or I
could then go to the producer and say
can you give me four more days to shoot
and they'll say no and then we'll say okay
in this case they had given me actually an
extra day because they knew it was big so it's
a nine-day schedule but it couldn't be done in
the nine days and so then my job as a director is
it's easy to say what can't be done the
real challenge and what distinguishes one
director from another is how much of a scripps
real value and merit can you can you realize
within the limitations how can you how can
you find other ways as they say to skin the
cat so the best way for me through that is a focus
always on story be as prepared as I can be and and
see what what time savers I can create that can
allow us to do a little bit more maybe than what
you originally thought so in this instance in
the chapter I write about in my book I focus on
only one of the sequences but it should be noted
that this I was prepping all of the sequences
simultaneously because you only have the eight
days to prep before you start shooting and this
one sequence was very complicated and it was the
opening stunt sequence so in this opening scene
this was the transition from season two
to season three and what the writers
wanted to show was the effect that the crack trade
was beginning to have on the community of South
Central Los Angeles so we wanted we wanted
to see a transition from the previous season
and the main character of this opening teaser
this opening stunt sequence is a police officer
who happens to be the father of a young woman who
is the girlfriend of the drug dealing protagonist
of the series I guess you would call him an
anti-hero because he's doing some pretty bad stuff
so he's got this internal family issue that his
daughter is his lovers with this drug dealer and
he's also committed to preserving his community
so what the epi what the scene dramatizes is you
start with him patrolling South Central and he's
seeing that there's signs of a change you see
young men on the corners wearing gold chains you
see others driving cars that they didn't used to
be able to afford and as he drives continues to
drive he sees a car stopped in the middle of the
street on a drug trade a drug deal going down and
there's a dealer in the car and there's a young
woman crack addict who's leaning in the car window
trying to buy dope so he pulls his car over walks
towards the car and the dealer sees him approach
and quickly tries to end the deal and says to the
woman get out of here but another way to show the
the way this drug has taken hold of the community
these the addicts of crack are so dependent on it
that she's she can't take no for an answer so as
he starts to pull away she jumps in the car window
the open car window with half her body outside
legs flailing reaching for the dope as he's
tearing off the policeman goes back to his car
tears off this is what's written tears off
after him after they go a certain distance
the woman grabs some crack off the seat falls
off the car collapses in an unconscious heap
the policeman comes up to her and thinking she may
be dead for all she he knows he gets out of the
car he comes towards her and just as he's about to
reach down to her she leaps up and tears off and
again meant to well whatever that she's got this
she's energized by this crazy drug and she wants
to get high and she's she's running away again
what's scripted she runs off and she goes by a car
parked somewhere and she tears off its antenna as
she's going and she stuffs as she's running she
stuffs the crack into the antenna I should
say that was a note john singleton who was
who who lived this story I mean in South Central
and not that he was a crack addict but he
he cre he was one of the creators of the show
and and he he'd always wanted to get this note
in because he thought that was kind of a cool
thing that he had actually seen someone taking
an antenna and making a crack pipe out of it
so she continues to run crap he the policeman
gives chase and loses her and when he
finally sees in the corner we see her
with inhaling from the antenna pipe blissfully
looking at him content for him to take her
anywhere he wants and the the end of the teaser
is meant is that he sees her and is aware
this drug is trouble this could ruin us if this
woman could go to these lengths we're all in
serious trouble all right that was the scene huge
stunt sequence to do to do safely and to do well
and to cover a lot of terrain and all that kind of
stuff so while I'm prepping the episode and but it
was also the kicker they lead into the season so
I really wanted to deliver an exciting sequence
so some of my considerations were these
well first of all while we're prepping this
we're prepping everything else too so we're
seeing how much time do we need to do that
and it felt to me like it was a couple of
days work to do this because it was also
in the height of winter so we had about nine hours
of daylight and there's lunch in between so to do
all of that car stuff to do a dangerous stunt
to do traveling big areas to do running through
backyards and all that stuff that's that's
hugely time consuming probably not doable
in in I mean two days would be a challenge to
do it and we didn't have time for that so we're
trying to figure out okay for the aerial flight
sequence we need this for that we need this for
the nighttime thing we need this and it was just
obviously seeming very big so the first thing
and I was talking to the showrunner
about okay he was interested in
how I was doing because he wanted as much in it as
he could I said well first let's think story here
this is a priority this this stunt sequence
obviously some of these other things we don't
have time for I don't think we have time for
this aerial sequence because first of all
it's very difficult to shoot that and secondly
it's not terribly important story wise it's just
what it dramatizes a pretty minor story point
it gooses it it makes it kind of exciting but
the story totally gets told without that so we
we decided early on okay we'll get rid of that
but we still had far too much to do but finally
we nipped and tucked and we did all that stuff
until we got to the point where we think we can I
think I can make just about everything else work
but the thing is we have to figure out a way to
do this son in one day I can't we can't have more
than one day to do it and then that became its
own challenge okay how can I possibly do this now
in trying to give the opening sequence the magic
I really wanted it to have the first two seasons
the pilot episode of the show had a beautiful
opening shot which was shot with an airborne drone
and it was in South Central l.a there the there
are a few streets that are have these enormous
beautiful thin status palm trees that line
the street and this particular opening shot
of the whole series from the first season was a
beautiful shot that started on the street and then
it rose up and it rose up and it revealed these
incredible trees that kind of presided over the
life the lives of everybody below and I wanted
to invoke that to say okay that was season one
now we're in the same place season three and
what's different so I thought okay first we
need to find a street that has these because there
weren't that many that have those that have those
trees and also it has to be appropriate for
the period which was 1984. so if if there were
inappropriate architecture we couldn't shoot
there we were able to find about two blocks
that were really good weren't the only two blocks
but they were they were pretty good they were two
blocks but what was written was much more than two
blocks first of all you have the guy the policeman
circling the whole community driving through it
establishing other things coming to another area
seeing this drug deal parking his car on the
side street coming over to them the car taking
off him going back to his car racing god knows
how many blocks and and and all that so he said
okay well that's going to be a challenge and
I also was struck by the story challenge of
well I started I said okay maybe what we could
do is if we use these two blocks and I can be
invented with my angles we can shoot them as if
they're many more blocks by changing our angles
having the car come in at different places so we
made a plan to do that then the most important
the biggest challenge was how to do this very
dangerous stunt safely I mean the stunt like
that is exciting because it's life-threatening
to see somebody hanging out of the car like that
and obviously we have to make it safe for the
stunt performers so how do we do that so I had to
I had to work with the stunt coordinator and the
cameraman and we worked out kind of a way to shoot
it and a way to bolt her in to have her connected
to the car when we see the car from the outside
she's she's not really she's has something
to hang on to but she also has to jettison
from the car too so it can't be a belt so it was
really I was very concerned about doing it safely
and we and we figured out several
things one we figured that
I also needed I said I realized I need a close-up
of her falling away from the car as well as a
shot from outside the car of her falling off
for a reason I'll talk about in just a moment
but what that pointed me to was that I needed a
stunt woman to be able to play the part because I
was going to be on her close-up as she's trying to
get the drugs and her falling away onto the street
so we had to find stunt people that could possibly
pull it off and we fortunately did and I realized
when we had her as a stunt person I said well
maybe if the stunt if the dealer could also be
a stunt man but there was real acting involved so
I had to audition several stunt people until we
found two people that we thought could do it but
that created a real time saver in that we didn't
have to tow the car ever it could be free driven
the stuntman could always drive the car himself
and we wouldn't have to put a car connected to
another insert car camera car and tow it that's
a big time drain would have meant we couldn't
do that couldn't do the show couldn't do the
scene in its full way so we'd save time that
way then I started to think about other issues
it's like now how does a this whole thing of her
running away how how does a physically fit cop
lose someone running away who's right there with
her she starts running she breaks off this thing
she does all this stuff he's giving chase how
does he how does she get enough distance to
to lose him that didn't make much sense to me
I mean it can be done but it just it would have
felt to me like a big cheat so I suggested
well why don't we instead of having the cop
go back to his car and give chase what if he just
runs after the car that's going off and and then
she'll fall off after one block which will shorten
the amount of terrain we have to cover and will
also make him winded when he gets there which
might justify him not being able to give chase
so that also enabled us to have to do a whole
company move to shoot the end of the car chase
it would just be right on our same two blocks
all right we did that it's it's really an epic
story I hope people are still following me but
everything that goes into these scenes you see
it's like it's I think some viewers sometimes
just watch a show as if oh yeah that happened
and you don't realize how many choices go into
every sequence you watch and how many decisions
are being made to present the scene in exactly
the way you see it because everything is a choice
in any case we started working on it more and
I realized okay this still isn't working and I
realized the thing in terms of the time we still
can't do this in one day and I realized the bridge
too far was this second chase and I went to I
went to the showrunner and I asked him what are
tell me about which is something I all like to
do a great deal of is to really confer with the
writers a lot to find out everything they
had in mind I mean I'll have my own take on
the material and I'll try to bring my own values
and and resources to bear but I really wanna I'm
really assisted by hearing from the writers
what exactly was in their mind what what is
the subtext what did they really whose point of
view is the scene what were you really working on
and the writer the showrunner a
guy named dave andron very talented
was saying well I really want to show the depths
to which these crack addicts will go to get their
fix and als and that's really why all this stuff
is happening and I thought okay so that's that's
what we want to show and I thought do we really
need because the thing that was adding to the
time was her springing up and running through
backyards and back alleys and him running
and imagining getting the camera and also having
to do tight insert shots of what she's doing while
she's running namely packing the pipe it just
would be a real real challenge to do quickly
and I thought maybe there's a way that everything
can happen at the first stop but how can we make
it deliver that same sense and so I came
up with this idea which I pitched to dave
I said what if she falls falls and rolls behind a
car so that only her back legs are visible to the
policeman running up to her and those back legs
are inert aren't moving so we think is she dead
is she unconscious and when he gets up to her she
could turn to him we didn't see her loading the
crack pipe and she turns to him exhaling oh she
could already have a crack pipe why does she's
an addict couldn't she just have her own pipe why
does she have to break off an antenna and so you
lose a little bit of interesting color and a note
and john singleton was sad to see it go but he got
it and and that she could just simply turn to him
when he's expecting to see her really harmed from
this terrible spill blissfully happy and then we
could rely on his face to tell the whole story
so with some reluctance dave the showman said
okay I get it all right so now we had a plan if
everything went perfectly we might be able to get
this all in one day but I also needed in addition
to that stunt I needed to shoot everything that
preceded it and I wanted an elegiac kind of oh
it's the right word a legend I don't know opening
shot that would recall that so it's like as
as he's going through the neighborhood I
wanted a shot that somehow would see these tall
palm trees and all that and I thought should
we mimic the drone shot that was in the
first episode but I thought better of that because
I thought that's not the story the story is I mean
I want to evoke that episode but the story here is
the policeman's point of view of what's happening
in this community so what I elected to do instead
was to start with a camera mounted on the roof of
the top of the cop car looking up we don't know
where we are traveling down the street seeing
these palms go by and then tilt down and end
over the light bar of the police car so it would
so that then we'd cut inside and we understand
we were in the point of view of the policeman
so we would evoke those palm trees and that world
but we'd establish what the story is which is this
is this man's point of view so all of these things
I'm collecting and all that and trying to figure
out how we're going to get done and I it worked
out with the cameraman efficient ways to shoot
shooting and and one way that we realized we could
do that was what you call chasing the backlight
always shooting into the sun so that you're going
to get nice lighting so that we'd start shooting
directionally one way instead of when you're not
shooting in the backlight sometimes directors of
photography need to artificially create that
which means lighting and the sun is the best
backlight you can use and it's also the quickest
trying to minimize how much lighting we used
anyway so after we figured all this work
that how the stunt could be done safely
and all that stuff we're ready to
shoot and I did a shot list and
when I showed up on the day of shooting my
sister rector said i've done a timing and
I think we're only going to get through about
two-thirds of the shots before we lose the light
so I heard him and I said okay but I
i wasn't convinced but I was concerned
and I just said well let's let's stick with
the plan and let's go and I just made sure
to move on as soon as I had what I needed
not get perfection but get what we needed
and I probably barked a little more than usual to
make sure everybody was anticipating okay what's
up next what's up next we also got two identical
period cars 1984 cars so that we could rig which
isn't easy when you're dealing with period cars
so that we could rig the interior the shot the the
shots that were required to be inside the car
on the characters we could rig lights on it and
keep another car free of any of those lights so
that we could just jump from one to another when
we're shooting outside the car and see the car
go by we did all those kind of things you do and
experienced crews knows to do and you accomplish
that in prep so we started shooting and it was
going very well and we got we got deep into the
stunt and everything was kind of working nicely
and then we got to the point where we had
to do the young woman's hurtling off the car
and as I mentioned before it was kind of critical
where she landed because she needed to land
behind half wheel half her legs out visible and
half in front and I realized how difficult that
is the stunt man was the stunt coordinator an
excellent stunt coordinator but as some stunt
coordinators do they can sometimes overestimate
what their people can do and he said oh she's
going to be able to hit that and I kind of okay
and we started doing the fall the shot of the
car going by and her hurdling herself off of
it so the car sh was meant to look like it was
going very fast because he was trying to avoid the
policeman and he couldn't go that fast because she
was going to have to time her jump and it was also
not as safe if he needed to slow down a little bit
so I did what we call under crank the camera
so that it would look a little faster and it
would make her her fall look a little
more herky-jerky and more dangerous too
and we shot the scene and shot the shot and
the first check just didn't work she just
it didn't work she just fell completely wrong
and it's okay take one no good let's do another
one and the second one we did and she did a great
fall problem is she didn't land anywhere near the
behind the car and I'm sitting everything with
the sun getting lower and all of us banking on
finishing this day and aware of how much
work had still to be done including the
the opening shot of the sequence which we're
going to wait till the sun was at its lowest
to get a beautiful backlight for this other thing
I knew I had to get to that too I thought I can't
ask this stunt woman to do this again she really
did a great job at skidding across a pavement
even if you're wearing pads it's got to be
painful and a lot of injuries can happen when
you do unnecessary additional takes of stunts
so I said what at least she had landed with her
facing away from the policeman so I said what I'll
figure something out let's just say it's fine and
we started to move on and and then I did a shot
of over the inert body teddy cam to get some
energy to tie them together as the policeman's
running towards her I go past her and meet the
policeman coming up and I told her on the ground
I said don't move until I tell you that we're past
you because I don't want to tip that you're still
alive and we did that and then I did a shot over
the charging policeman towards her and I told
her wait till I cue you to turn around because
I wanted him to get closer to her and the first
take we did she thought she heard my cue too early
and as he starts to run she starts to make some
movement and I said okay wait that was a miscue
you didn't hear that wasn't really me let's do
it again and she did it how I wanted her to do it
so we finished the sequence I'll talk about that
later but I'll jump to this that night I was after
the day it completed I thought successfully
I bolted up in bed because I realized oh my
god I made a terrible mistake I if she hasn't
moved at all until he gets there there's no way
she could turn to him and exhale this pipe how
would she have lit it how would that have happened
and I thought did I well I could do it in cuts
but it would just be a far inferior sequence you
wouldn't get any of the excitement of seeing
them all in the frame and all that and I was
beside myself until I remembered the miscue when
she turned a little too early and I thought okay
it's saved it won't be exactly as I thought but I
can still have the dynamic shots and an audience
will believe when they see her turning with the
lid pipe that they'll they won't be bumped they'll
still be with the story so a mistake had led to my
salvation so that's the kind of thing you got to
be present to what's happening so you can see
opportunities that you may have missed anyway
so we completed the sequence and I should say too
because it may be of interest to those of you who
are interested in editing that the reason I needed
the shot in close-up and the sh of her falling
away from the car which by the way she fell onto
a camera platform on the car she didn't go on we
didn't want her to hurt herself by doing that
unnecessarily so we had a camera platform below
you couldn't see when she dropped out she just
dropped onto a platform and joining that to the
shot of her the shot outside she couldn't really
create the necessary spring she needed to get all
the way across the lane unless she kind of jumped
but that's not what it was supposed to look like
it was supposed to look like she was a rag doll
and just had fallen off but by having the close-up
angle of her I was able to stitch together two
shots where I could go from the close-up angle
of her falling out of the frame and cut out the
false beat of her starting the jump from the
exterior shot so we could just cut to her being
a rag doll falling away and rag dolling all the
way over so that was the reason for the need for
the for the two angles of the stunt in any case
I i I'm hesitant to go much further I do detail
this in the book we ended the day racing to get
the opening sequence which was a complicated
shot as well because it involved timing the
background cue we're moving down the street seeing
these beautiful trees coming down over the light
bar seeing the street and I needed a few things
to happen that would justify a convertible car
which was a story point going by that we had a
second camera in the passenger seat of the car
so that then panned with the car going by ending
in a profile shot of the cop which was revealing
okay it's that guy and this is his scene and
we were racing to get it the everything was
in place and we but the sun was sinking we tried
it a couple times the timing didn't quite work
and we really only had one last chance to get it
with optimal lighting conditions which I really
cared about because it was quite beautiful and
I was sitting in the back seat of the car with
the operator with a handheld monitor because it
came because the camera angles were on top of the
roof and also in the seat in front of me looking
forward and we said one last shot and we this is
I love this because it shows you how collaborative
and how many how people bring so many talents to
bear to make something great and we started our
trip down the down the road and we're seeing and
I'm looking at the monitor and you're seeing these
beautiful trees going by and I'm thinking this guy
should pan down sooner he should tilt down we're
going to get we're going to miss the queue we're
going to miss the queue and it felt to me too
long and he had his own intuition and he kind of
tilted down iq background action and it was just
perfect and we had this beautiful introduction
and we finished it and it was just one of those
great feelings of accomplishment and it's it so
that when you get a script that looks challenging
and the easiest thing to do is say can't be done
but what's really great is to is when you
do pull it off by ex and and don't don't
resign yourself to telling a story less well
you can still find you can still if you really
stay fiercely committed to telling the story and
getting everything out of it you possibly can you
have you have a real chance often to really pull
something off that doesn't look very possible.